- All right, we have
reached the end of the hour,
but let's squeeze in one more great story.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience cheering)
The father-daughter dance is
a highlight at most weddings.
In California, a bride
and her dad used old video
to make the moment even more touching.
Take a look.
(gentle music)
Oh man.
So sweet.
The wedding was two years ago,
but the bride recently
posted it as a tribute
to her dad on his birthday
and it took off from there,
'cause it's the sweetest thing ever.
Let's get them in here.
Say hi to Rhiannon and Andy
watching on NBC Los Angeles.
(audience cheering)
Hi.
- Hi.
- Oh my gosh.
So whose idea was it to do the
video behind y'all dancing?
- We would love to take credit for it,
but it was 100% my mom's idea.
Long before I ever got engaged
or had met my husband even
she was like, "When you get married
"I'm gonna have that father-daughter
dance playing the video
"of you guys when you were little."
And she's an event planner
so she kind of stored it
away in the back of her mind.
And so, when the time
came, we dug out the video
and we kind of put it together.
We kept it as a surprise
from all of our guests.
So, that night was just
so full of emotion.
We were obviously emotional
and crying the whole time,
and really just the whole
room was crying with us.
So, she took a really special memory
and made it so much more special.
- Yeah, if anyone wasn't
crying, they have no soul.
That was so beautiful.
And it's especially to shock people
that like, they don't know it's coming.
Oh my gosh.
So, Andy do you remember making
the video the first time?
- Well, right now, Kelly,
we are actually in the room
that we made the video.
- Oh, y'all are like a country song.
Okay, this is like.
- This has been our house
for the last 40 years
and every time I walk in this room,
I remember making that video.
Yeah, it was a very special evening.
I was on my way overseas for a week,
and we really had no
videos of Rhiannon and I,
and my wife says, "We gotta
put something on film.
"We gotta get something."
So, Gaston was playing,
so we picked up and I was
twirling her around the room
to the Gaston video first.
And then my wife, she fast forwarded
to "Tale as Old as Time"
and as soon as that came on,
Rhiannon slapped her head
right against mine like this
and we went into this
magical moment of a dance
that I'll never forget as long as I live.
- Okay.
(audience clapping)
I wasn't even at the
wedding and I'm crying.
That is so you're the greatest dad.
Oh my God.
And your wife and your mom is so cool.
Everybody, I'm good.
Okay.
Thank you so much Rhiannon
for sharing that video.
Thank you, Andy, for joining us.
That was so super special.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
(heart dings)
- [Rhiannon] Thank you.
- [Andy] Thank you.
- Thank you, Kelly.
- And that's not all, actually.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate amazing
families just like yours.
I'm still trying not to cry.
So they're gonna give you $1,000.
(audience cheering)
Ah, y'all got me.
Okay.
Thank you guys so much.
- Thank you so much, Kelly.
- Your beautiful family
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Meg Ryan, David Duchovny, Cat Graham,
Lou, Sophia, and Daniel.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.